tamar braxton's fans are concerned after
reports surfaced that the star
attempted suicide
unconscious 900 boulevard according to
multiple reports
the 43 year old singer actress and tv
personality was found
unresponsive by her boyfriend david a
deficio
at the ritz-carlton residences in los
angeles where they were staying
in his 9-1-1 call david said tamar had
been drinking and had taken an unknown
amount of prescription pills
sources tell the blast that david
believed the incident was a possible
suicide attempt
the blast also reports that tamar is
currently in stable condition
but still unconscious she is currently
under
24-hour watch at the hospital i've been
feeling shocked
every single day this all happened on
the same day that tamar's new wetv
reality show tamar braxton get your life
was announced in a statement to et wetv
wrote
tamar braxton has been part of the wetv
family for nearly a decade we are
keeping her
and her family in our thoughts and
prayers and joining with her fans
sending strength
and healing at this difficult time i'm
one of those
women just like all the women in america
that i run into is that you know we
never give up
we do whatever it takes especially when
you're thrown into the position where
you're a single mom
it's like everything is hard but nothing
is too hard tamar is a mom to
seven-year-old son
logan whom she shares with her
ex-husband vincent herbert
it just goes to show you how resilient
we all are when we have to figure it out
in may tamar opened up to et about
co-parenting their son
and figuring out her relationship with
vincent after finalizing their divorce
but we're in a really really good place
you know we realize it's not about us
it's not about our feelings it's not
about what happened
you know it's about logan and it's about
us setting the best
example for him and being there for him
so that's the choice we made
but you have to make that choice
you